PROFESSOR: So we're slightly
into chapter seven, which is
the algebra chapter.
We're talking about a number of
algebraic objects, starting
with integers and groups
and fields.
Polynomials.
Our objective in this chapter
is simply to get to finite
fields so that you have some
sense what they are, how they
can be constructed, what their
parameters are, how you can
operate with them by addition,
multiplication, so forth, as
you would expect in a field.
Subtraction, division.
And that's really all
we're aiming to do.
I'm trying to give you a short
course in algebra, really, in
two lectures or fewer.
And clearly I'm going to
miss a lot of things.
In particular, I'm not going
to cover even everything
that's in chapter seven, which
itself is a highly compressed
introduction to finite fields.
I'm trying to do this while
remaining faithful to the
philosophy of this course and
other courses at MIT, which is
that you should really prove
everything and show why things
are true, and not simply
make assertions.
So it's a little tough and it
forces me to go a little fast,
but I hope that you can keep
up, and especially with the
assistance of the notes or the
many possible other things you
could read on this subject,
which are listed in the notes,
you'll be able to keep up.
And some of you, of course, have
seen this in other places
in more extended form.
Now, this will get us in a
position to start to talk
about Reed-Solomon codes, which
are the single major
accomplishment of the field of
algebraic coding theory.
Certainly for getting to
capacity on the additive white
Gaussian noise channel and for
lots of other things, they're
an extremely useful and widely
implemented class of codes.
And we'll be able to maybe just
get to the beginning of
that by Wednesday.
And then I won't be here again
next week, but fortunately we
have an expert on campus who is
far more expert than I in
Reed-Solomon codes, their
decoding algorithms, who has
agreed to talk for two lectures,
maybe one more
focused on Reed-Solomon codes
and one, I hope, on his whole
philosophy of life.
Perhaps.
I don't know how it's going to
come out, but I'll see it on
TV when I get back.
Anyway, Ralf Koetter will be
lecturer for Monday and
Wednesday next week.
I think you'll enjoy
the change of pace.
OK.
So where are we in
chapter seven?
We're not very far.
We're talking about these
various algebraic objects.
We've started with integers
just to get you
into the feel of it.
We mainly talked about integer
factorization, the Euclidean
division algorithm, things that
you've known for a very
long time, basically here
because A, we're going to be
using integers as we go along,
and their factorization
properties, B, it's a model for
polynomials, which behave
very much the same way as
integers because they're both
principal ideal domains.
In particular, we looked at the
integers mod n with the
rules of mod n arithmetic, which
we're going to call Zn.
This is simply 0 through n
minus 1 with the mod n
arithmetic rules.
And then we went on to groups.
We first gave the standard
axioms for groups, and then I
gave you an alternative set of
axioms which focused on this
permutation property.
If you add, I'm calling the
group operation addition,
because essentially all the
groups we talk about are going
to be abelian --
if we add a group element
to the group,
what do we get back?
We get the whole group again.
It's permuted, it's the
entire group, it's
in a different order.
All right?
And with this and the identity,
this plus the
identity and the associativity
axiom are also a sufficient
set of axioms for the group.
And I think this is really the
most useful thing to think
about with a group.
We've also called it the
group property when we
talked about codes.
You know, if you add the code
word to all the elements in
the code, you get
the code back.
And you saw how useful that
was for seeing certain
symmetry properties of minor
linear block codes.
So we even talked about cyclic
groups, specifically finite
cyclic groups.
And we showed that all
them basically are
isomorphic to z mod n.
A cyclic group is defined
by a single generator.
If we identify that generator
with one, G plus G is
identified with 2, and so forth,
then we get an addition
table which is exactly the same
addition table as Zn.
And that's what we mean when
we say two groups are
isomorphic.
So all finite cyclic groups
look like Zn.
You can think of them as
being images of Zn.
All right?
It's the only one you
need to know about.
OK.
So that's where we are any
questions on this material?
Pretty easy, I think.
Terribly easy if you've ever
seen any of this before.
Probably takes a little
absorbing if you haven't.
OK.
Now the next natural subject
to talk about is subgroups.
And what is a subgroup?
A subgroup simply a subset of
elements in the group which,
together with the group
operation already specified in
G, which we're calling circle
plus, is itself a group.
What does that mean?
Well, associativity comes for
free, because we already have
that property for circle plus
in G. Obviously H has to
include the identity in order
to satisfy the group axioms.
And finally, the third group
axiom is this permutation or
group property that if we add
any element of the subgroup to
itself, we have to stay within
the subgroup and ultimately
generate the whole subgroup.
That means that subtraction,
cancellation hold in the subgroup.
All right?
So that's clear.
What's an example
of a subgroup?
If we have --
we talked about Z10
as the group.
What would be a subgroup?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 0 to 4.
OK.
So you're proposing that H is
the elements 0, 1, 2, 3, 4 out
of G. Does that work?
This doesn't include 0.
But suppose I add 3 and 4?
AUDIENCE: I assume that you
have modules for a reason.
PROFESSOR: No.
In this group, the group
operations modulo 10 addition.
Subgroup has to have the
same operation as the
group it came from.
What you've got here is you've
already got, in essence, a
quotient group.
Or at least that's where
you're headed.
So this is not a subgroup.
Thank you for the suggestion.
Fails.
Anyone else?
What?
AUDIENCE: 0,1?
PROFESSOR: 0,1.
OK.
Let's try that.
And it contains the identity
0 plus 1 is
certainly in the group.
How about 1 plus 1?
It's not in the group.
0 and 5?
That sounds more promising.
Now, 0 plus -- what's the
addition table of this?
0, 5, 0, 5, 0, 5.
What's 5 plus 5?
It's 10.
But mod-10 , that's 0.
So it seems we do
have a group.
And in fact, this is a finite
cyclic group generated by 5,
and has two elements, so
it's isomorphic to Z2.
In other words, the addition
table looks just like the
addition table of Z2
with a relabeling.
OK.
Any other subgroups of Z10?
The even integers.
There.
Now we're really smoking.
H equals 0,2,4,6,8.
Those are all the even
integers in Z10.
And again, evens plus
evens equal evens.
So we get a group of five
elements, satisfies is the
group property, and it's
isomorphic to what?
Z5 --
yeah.
This is obviously the same group
is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, just
doubling everything.
Operates the same way.
So it's change of labels.
OK.
So there are some examples
of subgroups.
Let's take another
good example.
Let's just take the set
of all integers.
That's an infinite group.
Mathematicians call it cyclic,
even though it doesn't cycle.
What's a subgroup of that?
AUDIENCE: Even integers.
PROFESSOR: All even integers!
Very good.
Check.
Does that include 0?
Yes.
Does it have the group
property, even
plus even is even?
Clearly subtraction holds,
and so forth.
So this is the subgroup.
Interestingly, there's a
one-to-one correspondence
between Z and 2Z, so the
subgroup is as big as the
group itself.
You get into the whole issue
of transfinite numbers.
But that's not where
we're headed here.
OK.
We'll just keep that
in mind for now.
Obviously 3Z, 4Z, 5Z, and all
the multiples of n are going
to be a subgroup of the integers
for any integer n.
So more generally, we could
take H equals nZ.
What's a coset?
Coset is also, in the abelian
case, called a
translate of a subgroup.
A coset, for instance, is in the
form H plus G for some G
in the group, not
in the subgroup.
Now if G is in the subgroup,
we get nothing.
The coset is just H again by
the group property of H. So
the interesting cases are where
G is not in H. Let me
give you some examples.
Let's take G equals Z10 and
H equals 0,2,4,6,8.
You might call that 2Z10 It's
the set of all elements which
are twice the elements in Z10.
OK.
What is a coset?
If I add any element in
this group to H --
let's add one, for instance.
So H plus 1 consists of the
elements 1,3,5,7,9.
Well, that's interesting.
That seems to exhaust all
of the elements of Z10.
Let's take the Z equals the Z10,
and H simply equal to 0
and 5, which we might
call 5Z10.
And all right.
Now H plus 0, H plus 5 is
just equal to itself.
H plus 1 is equal to 1,6.
H plus 2 is equal to 2,7.
H plus 3 is equal to 3, 8.
H plus 4 is equal to 4,9.
So we begin to see some
properties of cosets here for
which proofs are given
in the notes.
First of all is that
two cosets are
either the same or disjoint.
H plus 2 is the same as H. H
plus 1 is completely disjoint
from H. Same over here.
If I had H plus 5, that would
be the same as H. H plus 6
would be completely disjoint
from H and would be the same
as H plus 1.
In fact, I can take any of the
elements of a coset as its
representative, and I'm going
to get the same coset, take
any element outside the coset,
and I'll get a completely
distinct coset.
This follows just very
easily from the
cancellation property.
All right?
So the cosets, the distinct
cosets, form a disjoint
partition of G. We certainly
have a coset that contains
every element of G. Just take H
plus that element G. That's
going to contain G because
H contains 0.
So there is a coset that
contains every element of G.
Any two cosets, distinct cosets,
are disjoint, so
that's what we mean by
a disjoint partition.
We list all the elements
of G in this way.
And in the finite case, that
gives us a early famous
theorem attributed
to Lagrange.
What does that mean?
This means that H has to divide
G. If G has size 1,10
and all the cosets have the same
size, by the way, again
by the cancellation
property --
this means that G has to consist
of an integer number
of cosets, all of which have
the size of H. OK?
And therefore some integer times
H is equal to H, which
is the same thing as
H divides G. OK?
If G is a finite group, I mean
by this kind of determinant
notation, the size of H. The
size of H divides the size of
G. Or more elegantly, the
cardinality of H divides the
cardinality of G. But
why say cardinality
when you can say size?
I shouldn't have put it here.
Where H is any subgroup, any
subgroup, of course, that's
finite is itself
a finite group.
So that's going to turn out to
be quite a powerful theorem.
And it just follows this
little exercise.
And we see it's satisfied,
certainly,
by these two examples.
In fact, it's pretty easy to see
that the subgroups of Zm
are going to correspond to the
divisors of m in the same way.
We're going to get a subgroup
for every divisor of m, and in
the case of cyclic groups,
this is the way it's
going to come out.
Just pick any divisor.
You get a subgroup
isomorphic to Zd.
Again, this is done with
more care in the notes.
Suppose we have the infinite
case here.
Suppose we have Z and 2Z.
So let me draw that case.
G equals Z. H equals 2Z.
And all right.
What's H?
H is the set dot dot dot minus
2,0,2,4, dot dot dot.
So this is H. And what's H plus
1, or in fact, plus any
odd number?
It's going to be the
odd integers.
H equals minus 1,1,3,5,
and so forth.
So again, this works in the
infinite case, that the
distinct cosets form a disjoint
partition of an
infinite group G. But of
course, we don't get
Lagrange's theorem as a
corollary, because I already
said, there's a one-to-one
correspondence between Z and
2Z, paradoxically.
So the cardinality of Z
and 2Z are the same.
More elegant language.
Nonetheless, you see, this
is a useful partition and
standard partition
into the even
integers and the odd integers.
And we could also write this as
2Z and this is 2Z plus 1.
So we can divide the
integers into even
integers and odd integers.
All right.
Now we can actually add cosets,
subtract cosets.
In these cases, we can
even multiply cosets.
But let's just talk
about staying
within the group operation.
Given any abelian --
let's continue to say
G is abelian --
how would you add two cosets?
Coset addition is defined
as follows.
H plus G --
we want to have some addition
operation, which I'll just
indicate by plus --
H plus G prime, what's
going to equal?
We define that to equal
H plus G plus G prime.
And that makes sense.
I mean, if we really write all
this out, we get H plus H plus
G plus G prime.
H plus H is just H again.
So it's sort of a
proof of that.
If you go through in detail, any
element of this coset plus
any element of this coset
is going to be an
element of this coset.
So this itself is a coset.
So we now have an addition
table for cosets.
So in fact, it's easy to show
that the cosets themselves
form a group called
a quotient group.
Start over here.
Cosets of H in G under
coset addition --
that's going to be Z --
form a group.
We just defined coset
addition.
And it's easy to check that they
themselves form a group
called the quotient group.
Usually written G slash H and
pronounced G mod H. And we can
can mod out anything.
We do the arithmetic in these
quotient groups by modding out
any elements of H.
And let's take an example.
Here's a good one.
For example, the cosets
of 2Z in Z, namely,
2Z and 2Z plus 1.
Under coset addition.
What is coset addition here?
If I add any even integer to
any even integer, I get an
even integer.
Any odd to even, I get
an odd integer.
Odd to odd gives that.
I mean, odd to even gives that,
and odd to odd gives me
back evens again.
So that's the addition table.
The subgroup itself,
x is the identity.
This is clearly isomorphic to
Z2 with this addition table.
In fact, this is a very good way
of constructing the cyclic
group Z2, or more
generally, Zn.
So this would be called
Z mod 2Z.
And it's isomorphic to Z2, or
in general, Z mod nZ is
isomorphic to Zn.
A very good way of thinking of
Zn is as residue classes or
equivalence classes, modulo n.
The cosets of nZ.
are nZ itself, nZ plus 1,
nZ plus 2, up to nZ
plus n minus 1.
And if you add them together,
they follow the rules of mod n
arithmetic.
If you just add the residues
together and
then reduce mod n.
So we can think of
Zn as being --
a coset is an equivalence
class.
It's all the elements of the
group that are equivalent,
modular of the subgroup H. Or in
the case of integers, it's
all integers that are
equivalent modulo
the subgroup nZ.
They have the same remainder
after division by n.
They have the same residue.
These are all equivalence
class notions.
And how do you add them?
You add them in the ordinary
way, and then you take
everything modulo m.
In other words, you do
mod-m arithmetic.
OK.
So I didn't quite go to quotient
groups in the notes,
but perhaps I should have.
Probably I should have, because
this is maybe the most
powerful idea in group theory,
and certainly closely related
to this little bit of number
theory that we're doing in the
integers mod n.
And of course, it has
vastly greater
applications than just that.
OK.
And you could do the same
thing over here.
This is basically doing the
same kind of thing.
But I won't take time
to do that.
So here's another view of the
integers mod-n that may be
helpful as we go forward.
All right.
I think that's all I want
to say about that.
Yeah.
Good.
All right.
Here would be a good place
to start on fields.
OK.
Fields.
Obviously very important
in algebra.
Fields are like groups,
only more so.
Groups are a set of elements
with a single operation, which
we've been calling addition.
A field is a set of elements
with two operations, which
we'll call addition and
multiplication.
So what do we have?
We have a set of elements F.
We're going to be particularly
interested where the
set is finite.
Those are called
finite fields.
And we're going to have two
operations, which I'll
continue to write addition by
simple plus and multiplication
with an asterisk, just to
be very explicit about
everything.
And after a while, you can
write these things as you
would in ordinary arithmetic,
with just ordinary plus and
juxtaposition for
multiplication.
And what are the axioms
of a field?
They're presented in an elegant
way in the notes,
which obviously go back a long
way, but I got from Bob
Gallager, and I like.
All right.
Under addition --
so let's write it this way.
Now, just considering the
addition operation is an
abelian group.
Commutative group.
Which means it has an identity,
and we will continue
to call that identity 0.
Just as we do in the real
field, let's say.
OK.
Think of the real field, if you
like, as a model for all
fields here.
All right.
So that's axiom one.
Axiom two.
If we take the non-zero elements
of the field, which I
write by F star, explicitly
that's F not including 0 --
not a very good notation,
but I'll use it --
and the multiplication
operation, that, too is an
abelian group.
So this, of course, is why we
spent a little time on groups,
abelian groups, so we'd
eventually be able to deal
with fields.
And its identity is called 1.
Meaning that under
multiplication, 1 times
anything is equal to itself.
And then we have something
about how the operations
distribute, the usual
distributive law that A times
B plus C is equal to A times B
plus D times C, where I've
written out all of these.
So this is how addition and
multiplication interact again
in a way that you're accustomed
to, and after a
while, you don't need to write
all these parentheses.
OK.
So that's actually almost a
simpler set of axioms than for
groups, once we understand
the group axioms.
And so let's check.
Is the real field, is the set
of all real numbers under
ordinary real addition and
multiplication, is that a field?
What do we have to check?
We have to check that under
addition, we're going to take
the additive identity
as being equal to 0.
Under our reduced set of group
axioms, the main thing we have
to check is if we add any real
number to the reals, we get
the reals again and the
one-to-one correspondence is
the permutation.
Is that correct?
Yes, it is.
And so this is OK.
Now under multiplication, if
we take the non-zero real
numbers, here's the question.
If I have some alpha not equal
to 0, is alpha times the
reals, not including 0 -- the
non-zero real numbers --
equal to R star?
And here I'm really implying a
one-to-one correspondence.
So I might write it
more that way.
I pose this question rather
abstractly, but you can easily
convince yourself
that it's true.
Any non-zero number, if I
multiply it by any non-zero
number, I get a non-zero
number.
Is the correspondence
one to one?
Yes, because I can divide out
this number and get alpha.
So alpha x on R star by
multiplication to give R star
again, and this is a one-to-one
correspondence.
But it's obvious why I have
to leave out 0, right?
0 times any real number is 0.
So at O, R star is simply
equal to zero set.
So we always have to leave out
0 from multiplication.
0 doesn't have an inverse.
Everything else does
have an inverse.
Under the standard group
operations, that's what we
have to check.
That would be the alternate
question, does every non-zero
real number have an inverse?
That's easier to see,
the answer is yes.
Multiplicative inverse.
Inverse of alpha is
1 over alpha.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I've used the alternative set
of axioms, including the
permutation property.
To check whether there's an
abelian group, I've asked if
alpha R star is the permutation
of R star.
And without going through
details, I claim it is.
Thank you.
All right.
So we checked that.
Of course, the distributive
law holds.
So the real field is a field,
which you probably were
willing to accept on
faith, anyway.
Similarly, you go through
exactly the same arguments for
the complex field.
What about the binary field?
We think we understand
that by now.
Here the operations are mod-2
addition and mod-2
multiplication.
I've written down explicitly
the addition and
multiplication tables.
Under addition, we simply
have Z2 again.
F2.
The additive group of
F2 is simply Z2.
We forget about multiplication.
We've seen quite a few times
now that that's a group.
Under multiplication, what are
the non-zero elements of F2?
Just one element. one.
This includes the identity?
Yes.
Is it a group?
Yeah.
It's a trivial group.
1 times 1 equals 1.
1 under multiplication is
isomorphic to the trivial
group 0 under addition.
Its group table is
1 times 1 is 1.
Sure enough.
That's the identity
permutation.
Sometimes when things get
too trivial, it's a
little hard to check.
But yes.
And distributive is
easy to check.
OK?
So that's all it takes
to define a field.
Of course, by the inverse
property, when we have
addition, this also implies an
inverse and a subtraction
operation and a cancellation
and additive identities.
We have a field element on both
sides of a plus b equals
a plus c, then b plus
b equals c.
That's what I mean
by cancellation.
Similarly under multiplication,
we get a
multiplicative inverse.
1 over alpha, for any alpha in
F. We, therefore, are able to
define division.
And we have cancellation for
multiplicative identity.
So we immediately get a lot from
these group properties.
We get all the properties
you expect of fields.
You can add, subtract, multiply,
or divide, all in
the usual way that we do
over the real field.
OK.
Let's stay over here.
I think my next topic
is prime fields.
Yes.
So prime fields.
When we talked about the
factorization properties of
the integers, we talked
about primes p.
And now I'm going to talk about
Fp is going to be a
field with a finite number
of elements where
the number is a prime.
So what are the elements in
this field going to be?
Are they simply going to be 0,
1 up through p minus 1 again,
the same elements as were in
the cyclic group with p
elements where I'm restricting
m now to be a prime p?
And for my addition operation
and my multiplication
operation, I'm going to just
let these be mod-p addition
and multiplication now.
And I claim that this
is a field.
So actually, the proof follows
very close to what I
just did for F2.
F2 is a model for this.
But it's a little harder
to check this.
Under a, under the addition
operation, Fp really is just
Zp again, so that's OK.
That's an abelian group.
Zmod-p.
Or the quotient group,
Zmod-pZ.
We can also again think of this
as Zmod-pZ, if we want.
So everything is going to become
mod-Z. That's a very
useful way of thinking of it.
So we're really thinking of
these as remainders or
representatives of the residue
classes of pZ in Z. This is
pZ, this is pZ plus 1 up
to Z minus 1, up to pZ
plus p minus 1.
This is the same
as pZ minus 1.
OK.
The real question is, if we take
the non-zero elements of
Fp, is this closed?
And does every element
have an inverse?
Or equivalently, when we
multiply by a particular
element, do we just get
a permutation of this?
The reason that p has
to be a prime --
let's suppose we take two of
these things, a and b, and we
multiply them.
What's the multiplicative
rule?
a times b is just ab mod-p.
That's what I defined
multiplication as.
Now the question is, could
that possibly be 0?
Which is the same as saying,
could a times b be a multiple
of p, where a and b are taken
from the non-zero
elements of the field?
And here, because p is a prime,
it's clear that you
can't multiply two non-zero
numbers which are less than p
and get a multiple
of the prime p.
If p were not a prime,
then you could.
If we took n equals 10 again,
let's say, and we multiplied 2
times 5 from the 10 elements
of these residue classes, 2
times 5 is, in fact, equal to
0 mod-10, and therefore Fp
star, or F10 star, would
not be closed under
multiplication.
We would get a 0.
But in this case, we easily
prove, because it's a prime,
that it's not equal to 0.
And therefore it's in Fp star,
so it is closed under
multiplication.
And the other thing we have to
check is that it's one-to-one.
In other words, can a star b
equal to a star c, and by the
cancellation property,
which holds in --
Sorry.
We've got to establish the
cancellation property holds
under mod-b arithmetic, but
it does, and so we get the
cancellation property, that
this is true if and
only if b equals c.
So in other words, as we run
through all of these multiples
for any particular alpha,
we're going to get a
permutation.
We need to get the
same set back.
Everything is finite.
We're going to get a bunch of
distinct elements of the same
size as the set itself.
Therefore, it has to
be the set again.
I haven't said that
very well again.
That's why we have notes.
It's written up correctly
in the notes.
But we have basically checked
everything that we need to
check, showed that Fp star
is an abelian group under
multiplication when p is a
prime, and clearly not when p
is not a prime.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the inverse, there
is inverse of a?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But basically, we have to prove
that if I take any of
these, if I take a particular
one, say, alpha, and multiply
times all of them in Fp star,
that I'm just going to get Fp
star again.
And to prove that, I have to
prove that alpha times a is
not equal to alpha times
b if a not equal to b.
That's all I need
to prove, right?
And that comes from the
properties of mod-p
arithmetic.
That is what is to be proved.
I need to use mod-p arithmetic
to prove that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh.
I have to check the identity
is in here.
The identity is in here.
It has one.
I'm sorry.
I should have checked
that, too.
But 1 is the identity
for multiplication.
And then from this property,
since we multiply alpha p
star, we get Fp star again.
That includes one.
All right?
So it's got to be one of these
guys which, times alpha, gives
1, and that shows the existence
of an inverse.
So you can do it any
way you want.
But the key to the proof is to
prove this, and that's why I
focused on the permutation
property.
Permutation property is
really what you prove
to demonstrate this.
OK?
Good.
Everyone seems to be following
closely here.
Any further questions?
This is important, because
we've got our
first finite field.
The integers mod-p are a finite
field of size p for any
prime state.
We've got F2, F3, F5,
F7, and so forth.
OK.
Further on this subject.
We have two closely related
propositions.
One, every finite field with
prime p elements is
isomorphic to Fp.
So if you give me a finite
field, you tell me it has p
elements, I'll show you that
it basically has the same
addition and multiplication
tables with relabeling.
And secondly, every finite field
with an arbitrary number
of elements, for every finite
field, the integers of the
field form a prime field for
some P. You understand my
abbreviations.
And the proofs of these are
very closely related.
What do I mean by the integers
of a field, of a finite field?
OK.
Well, let's start from the
very most basic thing.
What do we know?
We know that the field contains
0 and 1, and those
are going to be two of the
integers of the field.
So 0 and 1 are in F.
Let's use the closure
under addition.
Clearly 1 plus 1 is in F. We're
going to call that 2.
1 plus 1 plus 1 is in F. We're
going to call that 3.
And so forth.
And of course, since the field
is finite, eventually this is
going to have to repeat.
And from the fact it repeats,
you're basically going to show
that at some point, one
of these is going
to be equal to 0.
So there's going to be some n.
The first repeat is
going to be n
equal to 0 in F. OK.
So that's what I mean
by the integers.
The integers clearly form a
subgroup of the additive group
of F, to form a subgroup
under addition.
And in fact, a cyclic
subgroup.
I'm skipping over some of the
details here, but that's a
claim at this point that I
haven't really demonstrated.
But just from a subgroup
property, let's attack number
one up here.
Suppose we have a field with p
elements, and the additive
group of the field
has p elements.
It consists of the
same elements.
And by Lagrange's theorem, what
are the possible orders
of that subgroup?
What are the possible number of
elements in that subgroup,
the sizes of the subgroup?
The order of a group
is its size.
Well, it has to divide p.
There aren't many things
that divide a prime p.
There's 1 and there's p.
OK?
So the subgroup either has
a single element or
it's all of the group.
If there's a single element
-- let's to keep an
open mind here --
then what that means is that
if I take G and I add it to
itself, since it's a subgroup,
it has to give an
element of the group.
But there is only one element
of the group.
Let's say G is the single
element in this subgroup.
I guess it could only be 1.
Let's start out with one.
So suppose one is the only
element of the subgroup.
Then I get the equation 1 plus
1 equals 1, which by
cancellation implies
that 1 equals 0.
OK, well, that can't be true.
In a field the multiplicative
identity is not
the additive identity.
So that can't be true.
That would only be true if we
had a field with one element,
and fields implicitly always
have at least two
elements, 0 and 1.
F2 is the smallest
finite field.
I suppose we could set up a
single element that sort of
satisfies all these axioms,
but then, what is the
multiplicative group?
All right.
So this can't happen.
So that means this subgroup
has to have p elements.
It has to consist of all the
elements of the field.
So that means the integers are
all the elements of the field.
But now the isomorphism, then,
is that this is isomorphic Fp
under the isomorphism.
This corresponds to 2, this
corresponds to 3, and so
forth, in Fp.
You can see, you know, 2 is 1
plus 1, 3 is 1 plus 1 plus 1,
so 2 plus 3 is going
to be 5 1's.
Mod size the field, whenever
this cycles.
So this is going to
have to be p, and
basically, that shows --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to prove that it is isomorphical
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
multiplying 1 plus 1 into
1 plus 1 plus 1.
But it is typical --
PROFESSOR: I really
have only used the
additive property here.
I don't think multiplication
enters into it.
OK, here's where the
multiplicative
property adds in.
I have to prove not only that
this is isomorphic to Fp as an
additive group, but the
multiplication tables are
isomorphic under the
same relabeling.
So for that, I have to show
that 2 times 3, when I've
defined 3 and 3 this way, gives
me the same result as
multiplying 2 and
3 in F p mod-p.
But again, I could do this just
because sort of mod-p
commutes with addition
and multiplication.
If I multiply 1 plus 1, two 1's
times three 1's, so I'm
going to get six 1's, and that's
exactly what I get in
Fp, reducing everything mod-p.
So I have to check that also
to prove this isomorphism.
And this is done carefully
in the notes.
The distributive law holds
because the distributive law
holds for sums of n 1's.
1 plus 1 times 1 plus 1 plus 1
plus 1, it's going to be the
same regardless of where you
put it in, how you put the
parentheses.
OK.
So with some sorry hand-waving
here, we've basically given
the idea of how to prove this.
It's basically Lagrange that the
additive subgroup has to
be of size 1 or p, and we prove
quickly that actually p
is the only case that works.
And then we extend all the
arithmetic properties by just
observing they'll hold
for 1 plus 1 plus 1.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the line 1 plus 1 plus
1 like that?
Might we [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
1 is equal to 0.
What is actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]?
Should we state that 1 has
to be different than 0?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I guess I could simply get
around that by stating that
the multiplicative identity has
to be different from the
additive identity.
It clearly follows from this,
and I think I put it as an
exercise, 0 times any group
element has got
to be equal to 0.
So this is how 0 behaves under
multiplication from these axioms.
But 1, as the multiplicative
identity, has to satisfy that
rule, so clearly, 0
cannot equal to 1.
Unless, in some trivial sense,
there is only one element in
the groups if there's any
non-zero element.
So this implies that 0
is not equal to 1.
Just could have included
that as an axiom.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Assume a
and b [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Assume a and
b, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
does not include 0?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Yeah, you're right.
OK.
So it follows from this
that 1 is not 0.
Yeah.
I'm sorry I don't personally
have a lot of patience for
these fine details.
For mathematicians,
it's important to
keep them all in mind.
But my effort is to make these
propositions plausible enough
so that you can believe them,
and you can go back and read a
real proof and see that the
proof must be correct
intuitively, without just
mechanically checking it.
OK.
Let me just again outline
how this works.
It's very similar.
Again, given any finite field,
if we define the integers of
the field in this way, we show
that eventually they form a
cyclic group.
Their cyclic group
is something that
has a single generator.
The generator is 1.
So eventually it has to cycle
for some number n.
Now could n be a non-prime?
No, because this is a field, and
if n were non-prime, then
we would be able to find two
integers that multiplied
together gave 0.
And that's forbidden by the
axioms of the field.
So the only possibility is that
n is a prime, and in that
case, we have found what's
called a subfield, a subset of
the elements of the field which
itself is a field under
the field axioms.
And the field has p elements,
and we already know that every
finite field with p elements
is isomorphic to Fp.
So it can only be that the set
of integers is a subfield
which is isomorphic to
Fp for some prime p.
OK?
So within any finite field,
we're always going to find,
just by writing out the integers
and seeing how they
behave under the additive
property that there are
exactly p of them.
So every finite field has
a prime called the
characteristic.
The prime characteristic
of the field.
This is defined as the
characteristic.
The size of the integer subfield
is the characteristic
of the field.
And it has an interesting
property, a
very important property.
Suppose we take this p and we
multiply it by any field
element called data
in the field.
By the distributive law,
this is just equal to
1 plus 1 plus --
so what do I mean by this?
I mean beta --
whenever I write an integer
times a field element, I mean
beta plus beta plus
so forth, p times.
But this is equal to 1 plus 1,
so forth, by the distributive
law, I guess, times
theta, p times.
And what is this equal to?
This is equal to 0.
So this is equal to 0 times
beta, which fortunately I just
told you always must equal 0.
OK.
So the conclusion is that if
we add any field element to
itself p times, we're going to
get 0 for all beta in the
field where p is the
characteristic of the field.
Now in digital communications,
we're almost always dealing
with a case where the
characteristic of the field is
going to be 2.
The prime subfield is just
going to be the two
elements 0 and 1.
1 plus 1 is going to
be equal to 0.
So subtraction will be
the same as addition.
And in that particular case, we
will have that the sum beta
plus beta of any 2 field
elements in a field of
characteristic two is going
to be equal to 0.
Just as we had for code words
in binary linear codes.
Binary linear codes are not
fields, they're vector spaces,
but it's a similar
property here.
You add any element of field of
characteristic 2 to itself,
and you're going to get 0.
So this shows that addition is
the same as subtraction.
Beta equals minus beta in a
field of characteristic 0.
Which is a little bit
more general.
OK.
So we have some fields now, and
we find these fields are
the only field of prime size,
and that every finite field
has an important subfield
and a prime subfield.
And that has important
properties, consequences for
the field itself.
All right.
I think that's everything
I want to
say about prime fields.
Now we go on to the next
important algebraic object,
polynomials.
And again, it's hard to know
just how detailed to be,
because of course you've all
seen polynomials, and you
intuitively or formally know
something about their
algebraic properties,
their factorization
properties, and so forth.
So I'm going to go pretty
quickly, and this will be in
the nature of a review.
A polynomial --
maybe the simplest way --
how do you define
a polynomial?
What does it look like?
It looks like this.
F0 plus F1 times x plus F2 times
x squared, so forth,
plus Fm times x to the m.
That's what it looks like if
it's a non-zero polynomial.
Or even if it's just --
you could consider all 0
coefficients to be the zero
polynomial.
But in general, the convention
is, we write f of x equal to
that if x is non-zero.
What are these f's?
These are called the
coefficients of the
polynomial.
And where do they live?
We need the coefficients to
be in some common field.
You've often seen these in the
real or complex field.
Here they're going to
be in finite fields.
In particular, very
shortly, they're
going to be prime fields.
But in general, we'll just
say these f's have
to be in some field.
So we're talking about a
polynomial over F where F is
some field.
So there's always some
underlying field if there
isn't a vector space.
Some similarities between
this and vector spaces.
And we usually adopt the
convention that Fm is not
equal to 0.
All right?
So we only write the polynomial
out to its last
non-zero coefficient.
In general, this could go up
to an arbitrary degree, but
well, a polynomial, by
definition has a finite
degree, which means it has
a finite m for which the
polynomial can be written
in this way.
And if the Fm is the highest
non-zero coefficient, then we
say the degree of f of x is m.
So all polynomials have a finite
degrees, except for 1.
There is the zero polynomial,
which we have
to account for somehow.
And here we'll just call
it f of x equals 0.
Informally, it's a polynomial,
all of those
coefficients are 0.
But we'll just define it
by its properties.
Zero polynomial plus any other
polynomial is equal to the
identity under addition
for the polynomials?
What's the degree of the
zero polynomial?
Anyone have a definition for
the degree of the zero
polynomial?
Is this well-defined?
Undefined?
OK.
Well, I'll suggest to you
that it should be
defined as minus infinity.
This actually makes a lot of
things come out nicely, but it
is on the other hand, you
don't have to do this.
If you like, you can define
the degree of
0 to be minus infinity.
It's just a convention.
OK.
So the set of all polynomials
over F0.
What's x here?
I've got this thing x.
What should I think
of this as being?
Is this an element of a field,
or is it something else?
In math, it's usually called
an indeterminate.
It's just a placeholder.
It's something else we stick
in order to define the
polynomial.
It doesn't have a value,
in principle.
A comment is made in the notes
that with real and complex
polynomials, you often think
of x as being a real or
complex number.
In other words, you evaluate the
polynomial at some alpha
in the real or the complex field
by just substituting
alpha for x.
And in fact, two polynomials are
equal if they evaluate to
the same value for all the
alphas and they're
unequal if not true.
When we get to finite fields,
it's important this be an
indeterminate.
Because consider x and x squared
as polynomials over
the binary field F2.
What are the values of these?
We'll call this F1 of x equals
x, F2 of x equals x squared.
Then F1 of 0 is 0 and
F1 of 1 is 1.
Right?
If I evaluate these at field
elements, the two field
elements, I get 0 and 1.
F2 of 0 is equal to 0, and
F2 of 1 is equal to 1.
But these are not the same
polynomial, all right?
So x is not to be considered
as a field element.
It's to be considered just as
a placeholder, a way of
holding up these polynomials.
It's actually most important
in multiplication.
But we gather common
terms in x.
This is the multiplication
rule.
But it's just something we
introduce to define the
polynomial.
All right.
So the set of all polynomials
over F in x, or in x over F,
is simply written as F
square brackets of x.
That's the convention.
So that's what I will write
when I mean that.
And it includes all sequences
like this of finite degree,
starting at 0, ending
somewhere.
And also the zero polynomial.
How do you add polynomials?
Let's talk about the arithmetic
properties of
polynomials.
You know how to do this.
If you have F0 plus F1 plus F2
and so forth, you have some
other polynomial doesn't have
to be the same degree --
G of x is G0 plus G1
x, up there --
how do you add these together?
Component-wise.
Sum is F0 plus G0 plus
F1 plus G1 x plus 2x
squared and so forth.
That's an example.
So you basically insert dummy
0's out here above the highest
degree term in G. You add
them up component-wise.
The addition operation
is where?
In this field, you have addition
operation in that
failed field, so you
can do this.
And you get some result which
is clearly itself a
polynomial.
If all the coefficients are
0, you declare that
the result is 0.
Otherwise the result
has some degree.
If you add two polynomials with
different degree, the
degree of the resulting
polynomial is going to be the
higher degree.
If they have the same degree,
you could get cancellation in
the highest order term, and get
a result which is of lower
degree, all the way down to 0.
All right?
So addition is component-wise
the degree of the result is
less than or equal to the max
degree of the components.
So we do addition.
How do we do multiplication?
You all know how to do
polynomial multiplication.
Example.
F0 plus F1 of x times
G0 plus G1 of x.
What do you do?
You just multiply it
out term by term.
F0 G0 plus F1 G0 x plus F0 G1
x plus F1 G1 x squared.
You can combine these
two together.
And that's your answer, which
clearly is a polynomial.
So that's one way of doing it,
is multiply out term by term,
collect the terms.
The result of this is that what
you get is a convolution
for each of the coefficients
in the new polynomial.
You convolve, just by the
ordinary rules of polynomial
addition, you can basically turn
this around, you convolve
it, and you'll get these
coefficients.
This is written out
in the notes.
So we know how to do polynomial
multiplication.
What are some of
its properties?
How is this defined
again in F?
We see we're now going to need
the multiplicative of
properties of our field F.
All of these products and
ultimately convolutions are
performed in F. That's why we
did these coefficients to be in
a field, so we can do all
these things.
All right.
What are some of
the properties?
What is the degree of the
product of two polynomials?
It's going to be the sum
of the degrees, right?
Provided that both the
polynomials are not 0.
The highest non-zero term is
clearly going to be a term of
this kind, and it's going to be
a coefficient of x to the
sum of the degrees.
And since F1 and G1 are both
non-zero, by the way we write
polynomials, them this
highest order term
is going to be non-zero.
But we also have to basically
have another rule that 0 times
f of x is equal to 0.
So that's the way we
multiply by 0.
And how does the degree formula
work in this case?
Well, this is why I defined
the degree of
0 to be minus infinity.
So the degree of the product
0 times f of x is --
I've defined this to be the
degree of 0 plus the
degree of f of x.
This is finite.
This is minus infinity.
So the sum is minus infinity,
and so it holds.
OK?
That's why we defined
the degree of
0 to be minus infinity.
We don't have to, but it's just
so that the sum of the
degrees formula continues
to work, even if we're
multiplying by 0.
Is there a multiplicative
identity for polynomials?
Yeah.
What is the multiplicative
identity?
1.
OK.
So one times f of x is
equal to f of x.
So that's one of the properties
of a field.
Gee.
The set of all polynomials over
F in x, is this a field?
Let's go back and check
our field axioms.
Under addition, does f of
x form an abelian group?
Does it have the
group property?
If we add two polynomials, do
we get another polynomial?
Do we have cancellation, if F1
plus F2 equals F1 plus F3, is
it necessarily true
that F2 equals F3?
Yeah, it is.
In fact, this looks very
much under addition.
These look like vectors.
If we confine ourselves to the
set of all polynomials of
degree m or less,
we can add them.
And it looks very much like the
vector space f to the m.
Set of all polynomials of degree
m or less corresponds
to the vector space Fm, which
does have the group property
under addition.
So in fact, for f of x, yes.
It is an abelian group under
addition with identity being
the 0 polynomial.
And all of f of x is an infinite
abelian group.
If we just take polynomials of
degree m or less and restrict
Fp to be a finite group, then
there are only p to the m
elements, and we would have
a finite abelian group.
OK.
Well.
Are the polynomials an abelian
group under multiplication?
It has an identity.
It has all the arithmetic
properties you might expect.
It's commutative.
f of x times g of x is equal
to g of x times f of x.
So it's abelian.
It has cancellation.
f of x g of x is equal
to f of x h of x.
That's true if and only if g
of x is equal to h of x.
Is it missing anything?
Inverse, right?
Very good.
Just like the integers.
Not all the polynomials
have inverses.
Which are the polynomials
that do have inverses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
There are more than that.
So now we're getting into
polynomial factorization.
And the particular topic
is units, which are the
invertible polynomials.
And what are they?
Does the 0 polynomial
have an inverse?
We're a little unsure, are we?
What could it possibly be?
If it had an inverse,
this would mean 0
times f of x is --
well, 0 times f of x would have
to be a one-to-one map to
all of f of x.
But it isn't.
It simply maps to 0.
Doesn't have an inverse.
What about the non-zero
polynomials
that have degree 0?
In other words, the degree
0 polynomial, is simply
something that looks like this.
fx equals f0, where f0
is not equal to 0.
Is that invertible?
Yeah, because f0 is in the
field, and it has an inverse.
So this has inverse 1 over f of
x, if you like, equals just
f0 minus 1.
1 over f0.
By the rules, you multiply
these two
things, and you get 1.
OK.
So the units in this --
well, I'm sorry.
Take a degree 1 or a higher
polynomial --
does that have an inverse?
Let's suppose we take a
degree 1 polynomial --
say, F0 plus F1 x --
and what I want to find
is its inverse.
Let's call it g of x.
Is it possible to find a g of
x such that the product of
these two is 1?
Clearly not, because by our
degree rule, what is the
degree of this product
going to be?
The degree is going to be the
sum of this degree plus this
degree, the degree of f plus
the degree of g, which is
going to have to
be at least 1.
Provided that g of x is not 0,
but clearly g of x is not the
solution we're looking
for here, either.
So this can't be true, and the
invertible polynomials are the
degree 0 polynomials, which
means they're basically the
non-zero elements of F. Yes.
Considered as polynomials.
AUDIENCE: And how are the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, indeed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, no.
We haven't introduced modulo
polynomials and right.
The powers and the indices are
the integers from 0 up to some
finite number.
OK.
It's time to quit.
We'll finish this.
We'll, I believe, to be able
to certainly finish chapter
seven, maybe get a little bit
into chapter eight, next time,
on Wednesday.
And we'll see you then.